(upbeat music)
- There have been a lot of
news about ChatGPT lately
like people using ChatGPT to write essays,
ChatGPT hitting a hundred million users,
Google launching Bard to
compete against ChatGPT
and Microsoft integrating ChatGPT
into all their products,
and also the viral sensation
of CatGPT where it can
answer all of your queries,
but as a cat, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow.
ChatGPT, if you don't know
already, it's a chat bot
by OpenAI where you
can ask it many things.
For example, explaining complex topics
like explain why I'm a
disappointment to my parents
or ask it more technical questions like,
how do I inherit more money
than my brother from my parents?
A lot of people are using it
to write essays, draft emails,
and even write code.
So I tried it myself, of
course, as a YouTuber obviously,
my first question to it
was, who is Joma Tech?
And it answered...
Are you fucking--
You know, ChatGPT has
a lot of limitations,
like here we ask it to name colors
that don't have the letter E in them,
and this is what they gave us.
Orang, yllow, red, that's clearly wrong.
In all seriousness,
this is to demonstrate how ChatGPT works.
It's a pre-trained large language model,
meaning it was trained on text data
from the internet until the end of 2021.
So it won't know anything
about things that happened recently.
It doesn't have access to the internet.
It'll only predict the answer based
on what it has consumed already,
and the way it answers your question is
by predicting each word that comes next.
For example, if you ask GPT who Bard is,
it's not going to know.
You might ask Joma, didn't
your channel launch in 2017
and ChatGPT was trained on
internet data until 2021,
yet it doesn't know who you are?
Yeah, so there's actually
a technical reason
and fuck you.
Recently ChatGPT hit a
hundred million users.
It launched November 30th, 2022,
and this article came
out February 3rd, 2023.
So it took two months to
hit a hundred million users.
Who are these users and what
are they doing with ChatGPT?
Well, it's pretty obvious,
they're cheating with it.
Everybody's cheating such that
some school districts have
banned access to ChatGPT.
If they can write essays,
then they can pass exams.
ChatGPT was able to pass
exams from law school,
business school, and medical school.
Three prestigious industries.
Now, this is why I went into coding
because I always thought that law school,
business school, and medical school,
it was too much about memorization
and you're bound to get replaced,
it just wasn't intellectual
enough, you know?
All right, well,
I guess engineering is
getting replaced, too.
ChatGPT passes Google coding interview,
which is known to be
hard, but I guess not.
But note that it is for a L3 engineer,
which means it's a entry
level, for those not in tech,
there's no L2 and L1, it starts at L3,
but this does raise questions
about ChatGPT's ability
to change engineering jobs behind it,
and we're already seeing the change
as Amazon employees are
already using ChatGPT
for coding even though
that immediately after,
they told them to stop, warning them not
to share confidential
information with ChatGPT.
What's happening is
they're feeding ChatGPT
internal documents,
which are confidential,
but OpenAI stores all that data.
You know, it reminds me
of when I used to intern
at Microsoft and they
didn't let us use Google
for searches because they think
that they might spy on us.
I was like, relax, I'm an intern.
I'm not working on anything important.
In fact, I actually wasn't working at all.
You know, I was playing Overwatch all day,
but yeah, anyways, they forced
us to use Bing for searches.
One thing that's being underreported
in mainstream media is the
success of GitHub Copilot.
It's probably the most useful
and most well executed AI
product currently out there.
Have I used it?
No, I haven't coded in forever.
Now, here's how it works.
The moment you write your code,
it's like auto complete on
steroids, like this example,
it helps you write the whole
drawScatterplot function
and it knows how to use
a D3 library correctly.
Another example here,
you can write a comment
explaining what you
want your function to do
and it'll write the code for you.
Sometimes even the name
of the function will give
it enough information
to write the rest of the code for you.
It's very powerful
because it's able to take your
whole code base as context
and with that, make more
accurate predictions that way.
For example, if you're
building a trading bot
and you write the function
get_tech_stock_prices,
it'll suggest, hey, I know you're going
through a rough time,
but building a trading bot is not going
to fix your insecurities and
maybe you should just accept
that you'll be a disappointment
for the rest of your life.
Okay.
How did all of this happen?
Why is AI so good suddenly?
The answer is the transformer model
which caused a paradigm shift
on how we build large
language models, LLM.
By the way, this diagram
means nothing to me.
It makes me look smart, so
that's why I put it on there.
Before transformers,
the best natural language
processing system used RNN,
and then it used LSTM,
but then Google Brain published a paper
in 2017 called "Attention is All You Need"
which is also my life's motto
because I'm a narcissist.
The paper proposes a
simple neural network model
they call transformer, which is based
on the self attention mechanism
which I don't fully
understand, so I'll pretend
like I don't have time to explain it
but I also know that it allows
for more parallelization
which means you can throw more hardware,
more GPUs to make your training go faster
and that's when things got crazy.
They kept adding more data
and also added more parameters
and the model just got better.
So what did we do?
We made bigger models with more parameters
and shoved it a shit ton of data.
Sorry, I'm trying my best
here to make the model bigger.
All right, fuck it.
Anyway, that gave us ready
to use pre-trained transformer
models like Google's Bert,
and OpenAI's GPT, generative
pre-trained transformers.
They crawled the whole
web to get text data
from Wikipedia and Reddit.
This graph shows you how many
parameters each model has.
So as you can see, we've
been increasing the number
of parameters exponentially.
So OpenAI kept improving their GPT model
like how Goku kept
becoming stronger each time
he reached a new Super Saiyan form.
While editing this,
I realized how unhelpful the
"Dragon Ball" analogy was.
So I want to try again.
To recap, transformer was
the model architecture,
a type of neural network.
Other types of models
would be like RNN and LSTM.
Compared to RNN, transformers don't need
to process words one by one,
so it's way more efficient at
training with lots of data.
OpenAI used the transformer
model and pre-trained it
by feeding it a bunch of
data from the internet
and they called that
pre-trained model GPT-1.
Back then, NLP models would
be trained from scratch
for a specific task like
translation or summarization.
Both transformer, we get to
pre-train the model first
then fine tune it for a specific task.
Then for GPT-2, they did
the same thing, but more
and with a bigger model, hence
with 1.5 billion parameters,
and then with GPT-3,
they went crazy and gave
it 175 billion parameters.
However, just like raising a kid,
just shoving it with a bunch
of information unsupervised
might not be the best way
to raise a kid.
She might know a lot of things,
but she hasn't learned proper
values from her parents.
So that's why we have to fine
tune it, tell it what's right,
and what's wrong, how not to
be racist and clean up its act.
That's GPT-3.5, a more
fine-tuned version of GPT-3
with guardrails that can
be released to the public.
Now you have a decently well-behaved kid,
but you now want to show her
off, so you dress it up nicely,
get her ready for her first
job, AKA more fine tuning
with some supervised training
so it behaves properly as a chat bot.
That way it's well packaged
and is ready to ship
to the world with a web UI.
Okay, back to the original
shitty "Dragon Ball" explanation.
So you can think of Goku's hair,
like the number of parameters,
175 billion parameters,
which is why you can see
Goku has more hair now.
Goku hair isn't much longer,
but it's just styled a
little bit differently.
100 trillion parameters.
So technically GPT-3 was already amazing
but OpenAI was able to
package it neatly with ChatGPT
which made it user friendly,
so it became a viral sensation.
So yeah, packaging is important.
It caused everyone to really
pay attention to this.
So how did people react to
the viral growth of ChatGPT?
People were mind blown
and said, Google is done
because ChatGPT is going
to replace search engines.
No, it can't.
Until it can search for porn,
it cannot replace search engines.
Oh, wait, why search for porn
when you could generate it?
(upbeat music)
Anyway, even losing a bit of search volume
to ChatGPT would be a big deal for Google
since 80% of their revenue comes from ads
and most of it comes from search.
People were telling Google
to release something similar.
Google was like, bruh, we have LaMDA,
which is basically ChatGPT,
but releasing it would be risky
as they had much more
reputational risk at stake
and has to move more conservatively
than a startup would.
That's foreshadowing by the way.
Microsoft is chilling.
They positioned themselves really well
by investing $1 billion in
OpenAI early on in 2019.
That allowed OpenAI to
leverage Microsoft's Azure
for its compute power to
train and run their models
and Microsoft gets to
integrate OpenAI's tech
into their products.
So if OpenAI succeeds,
Microsoft succeeds and
remember GitHub Copilot?
Well, GitHub is owned by
Microsoft, so that's a huge win.
Meanwhile, Google is panicking
and issued a code red,
calling in the OG founders Page and Brin.
Actually I have no idea who's who, so...
Anyways, but they called
them to strategize
on how to approach this.
Microsoft is fueling
the momentum, especially
with ChatGPT growing so fast
and the tech is very promising.
So Microsoft invests another $10 billion
into OpenAI for a 49%
stake in the company.
That money can help OpenAI,
I don't know, unlock
Super Saiyan 4, maybe.
Microsoft also plans to integrate GPT
into Microsoft Teams
following the same playbook
as what they did with GitHub Copilot
which would be huge for them.
Google also made some additional moves.
Google invests almost $400 million
in OpenAI's rival Anthropic,
which is pocket change compared
to the $10 billion Microsoft invested.
If you don't know what
Anthropic is, it doesn't matter.
It's like the Burger King of OpenAI.
Google goes back on their word
about not launching a ChatGPT clone
and announces Bard AI, a ChatGPT clone.
Remember when I said
they didn't wanna launch
a ChatGPT competitor because
of reputational risk?
Well, funny enough, that's
exactly what happened.
The AI made a mistake in the ad
and Google shares tanked,
losing a hundred billion dollars
and I still own my Google
stocks from when I worked there.
The mistake was Bard said,
"JWST took the very first pictures
"of a planet outside of
our own solar system."
But this astronaut said, "No,
it was not true, Chauvin did."
That tweet alone cost me a lot of money.
Anyway, Microsoft responded
to the announcement
by releasing a new Bing
with ChatGPT built in
to compete with Google search.
Meanwhile, we have Meta, who is in denial.
Meta's AI chief says,
"ChatGPT Tech is not
particularly innovative."
That is just massive copium.
Finally, we got Netflix,
who's too busy cracking
down on password sharing
to care about AI.
All right, what about us engineers?
What's the future for us?
The reality is
that GPT isn't replacing
anybody's job completely.
Like most technological innovations,
that change can seem drastic
because the media loves dramatic titles.
But if you're open-minded,
you have time to learn
about it and embrace it
rather than fighting it.
If you're a software engineer
and you feel threatened
by ChatGPT being able
to solve FizzBuzz, oof,
then you should maybe
consider becoming a YouTuber.
Just kidding.
Please don't compete with me.
Though, you should incorporate ChatGPT
and GitHub Copilot to your workflow.
It really removes tedious
parts of software engineering.
If you're working in a new
language or API library,
you don't have to Google, sorry, Google,
you don't have to Google endlessly
for the stuff you already know.
Just break down and describe your problem
to ChatGPT to get a huge headstart
or get good at coding alongside Copilot.
If you structure your code base well
and write good comments that
describe what you want to do,
Copilot often gets the
logic problems right.
It's a symbiotic relationship.
Become the cyborg.
See, the trick here is that,
as a software engineer,
your job is to translate
and break down a business
problem into software problems.
Your job is to know what questions to ask
and what answers to accept.
In fact, here's my prediction.
GitHub Copilot is not
done innovating here.
Their next big product
release will turn an issue
or PR description into an
actual full-blown code commit.
So as a software engineer in
2024, you better get real good
at writing GitHub issues
and reviewing PRs.
All right, that's it
for this ChatGPT video,
but I think this ChatGPT
narrative is just one battle
of a bigger AI war that's happening
between Microsoft and Google.
I'll talk about that next time.
See you and thanks for watching,
and remember to call your parents.
(upbeat musical effect)